greetings [__] it's a beautiful
[__] day to be alive Monday
morning July the 2nd what the [__] are
you thinking
it's Monday [__] when the tides
of life are against you undercurrent
upset your boat don't waste those tears
I'm what might have been just lay on
your back and floating Ed Norton 1951
[__] uncle Joey direct on a
Monday morning my god that's cousin and
I got more [__] dead stab me
this is the [__] killed homeroom
collection from [__] North Korea he
grows this weed in the back with the
[__] arsenal you understand me but
anyway it's a beautiful day to be alive
it's cloudy out it's humid who gives a
[__] jack I'm ready to [__] go I've
been right 9:00 a.m. [__] kick boxing
conditioning and I'm going acupuncture I
got a few [__] meetings I'm weighing
in tonight at Weight Watchers I'm a fat
[__] and that's it and that's that
the church were taking a week off Joe
Rogan 11:00 a.m. the fourth the [__]
July uncle Joey and [__] the roman
candles you understand me this is how we
[__] do it scratch your balls
and sniff your fingers this is what the
July this country's 240 something
[__] years old sniff your finger
salute the flag and let them know you're
coming in big but Joey what's with the
[__] ear beatin let's park what I
said
we got the ending of this debt over here
this is [__] high octane are you
[__] kidding me or what I [__] when
they call it weed high-octane you know
you're gonna have [__] problems you
understand me here we go let's get this
party started it's Monday I know you got
things to do you're probably working
Monday Tuesday Wednesday you spend it
with your family break the [__]
bottom off those [__] tremendous I'm
going to Chinatown like by Chinese
[__] firecrackers and selling to all
the [__] dumb kids that wouldn't
didn't have the balls to go to [__]
Chinatown and don't forget steep Bay
against my man Cormier this [__]
weekend let me tell you something you
know I love Kwame he's a [__] savage
but you kind of give the edge to steep
everything they're throwing at steeper
he [__] cuts down so whatever I'm not
betting I'm just here to have a good
time we came to get down we came to get
down but Joey you're gonna [__] spark
are you gonna [__] talk let's bark
dog suck
Oh tip number two don't try to pick
popular dude will never happen you
understand me I seen an acidic jus
yesterday at the part with a $10 bill
hanging out his pocket I follow him
around for an hour I had my daughter
bumping into him
you can't pick pocketed you don't even
worry about it anyway you live and your
[__] learn 55 I'm still swinging dick
and I'm still holding my own you
understand me why cuz I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] that's the
number-one thing about this game you
cannot give a [__] because if you start
giving a [__] that's how you end up in
therapy and what am I gonna do I learned
from a great friend of mine Mike running
when I was 17 years old can't give a
[__] release that [__] I begin when I
do give a [__] that's when I [__] up
that's what my [__] side comes out I'm
a [__] animal I'm a freak without
warning my appetite for sex makes me so
horny me so horny me so horny me so
horny
we love you long did you do them anyway
what do you want done you want me to sit
here and give you a [__] a beating
about what it's Monday relax have a good
time
who gives a [__] yeah I'm saying let me
shoot some videos this week lunch with
uncle Joey maybe some sushi couple
[__] edibles you know how we do it and
that's it and that's that I sit back and
enjoy the [__] ride it's Monday who
gives a [__] so fourth of July weekend
relax make your notes this is the last
six month run of the year plan the last
six months run of the year are you gonna
end out 2018
on top of these [__] like
LeBron James you tell me you understand
154 [__] million dollars are you
kidding me only one person got more
money a little Chinese dude I got beat
up on United that [__] dude got like
200 millions on an island right now
nobody's even got a postcard from
[__] Mingo anyway it's a beautiful
week brothers I'm looking good I'm
feeling good and that's all that [__]
matters we're gonna weigh in tonight
every week an inch a pound a [__]
half pound whatever it don't [__]
matter you were gonna stick around her
daughter the [__] race and I got a
couple of things I gotta finish you guys
know what I'm talking about but besides
that it's a beautiful [__] day you
got the world by the balls you're yummy
I'm 55 I got one foot in the grave one a
banana peel and I'm still swearing like
a [__] you're sitting there
taking your world is over you [__]
[__] yeah I said the [__] word I
don't give a [__] uncle Joey's periscope
is not politically correct if you're
under 18 hang up now your dirty little
[__] anyway this is the best [__]
nation in the world you sitting there
what am I gonna do I got a [__] can
of [__] psychotherapy pills but let me
tell you something every morning you
gotta get up like you own this
[__]
even if you fake you go out there and
[__] fake the funk until you get the
fun you follow me I'm not even listen
I'm not even talking about the bridge I
cross crosses economy I'm talking about
the bridge that I cross as a human
[__] being you know I'm saying where
I was on where I am today is two
different [__] places and if I did it
you could do it I got PTSD the Mack you
don't see me [__] talking about it I
don't know what PTSD coming from all
directions I'm not worse than the
[__] football player but you know
what [__] it I spoke my reefa i time the
voices down and every day I get up with
two [__] hands and I play for keeps
and that's all I [__] do that's it
and you if I could do it and I'm [__]
felling left back in the seventh grade
GD can you imagine what you could do
with a family and a little good smile
and I got a Bella [__] smile
it's [__] Monday [__] take the
stick out of your ass uncle Joey's
coming to town Las Vegas the 13th and
14th the 27th is [__] tickets not for
the set 8 o'clock show over in Utah
Kansas City that nine to the 11th
[__] hunters al Alabama were coming
on Thursday August something then we're
in Nashville for a weekend demo in
[__] Philadelphia at the posh casino
then what the [__] BC at the 9:30
club with a listen we'll come don't
worry about it right you know me I just
can't I'm an old man I got the but I
forgot the kid I'm trying to [__]
Harvey proof or follow Joey the hairdo
of debt I'm losing two hairs a day but
who needs hair 55 the hair I got served
its [__] purpose I don't give a [__]
if it all falls off I'll walk around
eating chemo bill staring people in the
eye what
and that's it and that's that you got
the word do what the [__] you need to do
you understand me stop feeling sorry for
yourself
stop with the depression stop with the
dare stop with that look at Anthony or
gives a [__] you're you you're you
[__] grab your ball straight to
[__] on a protein shake and get out
there and let these [__] know
you no [__] around today you
understand me that's it that's that any
questions oh yeah they didn't get my
matter I bring our a salad located in La
Punta opinion our mundo do your pocket
Jose Antonio Lea or fool be eagle-eye
Santissima how is it to know ya panel
Sampha back hello sapa anyway I love you
[__] with all my heart no
church this week we're taking the week
off just Joe Rogan Wednesday fourth of
July I'm coming straight into your
[__] living room before you like
fireworks or your family [__] right
there you can let them know this is my
uncle Joey fresh out of jail whatever
the [__] anyway I love you have a great
[__] day I'll be in touch with you
[__] all week
you know I'm a minor am I don't [__]
belly-to-belly sales always I love you
[__] don't let nobody [__] with
you today I got your back I'm with you
you with me and they wanna be with us
remember that stay black have a great
day I'll see you later